vraiment on me confirmer ya aucun
trucage vous ne connaissiez pas la
personne monsieur monsieur le
responsable ça c'est pas les balles à
jay se voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez petit intermède divertissement au
tour de magie c'est par ce deuxième
quart
alors voilà c'est parti je vais vous
demander n'aura de choisir une carte je
ne veux pas la boire je ne la connais
pas je ne veux pas en entendre parler
montrer leurs travaux à me montrer la
voa me montrer cette carte que je vais
essayer de retrouver tout de suite rome
était là dans le paquet voilà un peu
mieux voilà c'est parti je vais vous
demander s'il vous plaît tout mélanger
[Rires]
tu veux demander à monsieur semoun de
coupe est à mon avis un truc à vous est
toujours étonnant les magiciens découper
bombe à la basse et j'espère que je vais
la trouver
ce n'est pas cette carte je le sais ça
n'est pas celle ci n'ont lu je vais
peut-être laissé celle-ci peut-être en
aura besoin
ça n'est pas celle ci ça n'est pas celle
ci et là je vais demander à siri
l'annulaire de retourner cette carte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez-y coup là bas c'est dingue si
c'est celle ci s'est alors si c'est ça
pour le diable si c'est cela les im si
je suis je rigolais si c'est celle là
moi je crois
[Applaudissements]
vraiment on me confirmer il ya aucun
trucage vous ne connaissez pas la
personne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donnez tous votre divertissement juste
une clé de douze rendre le cours normal
de ses vrais amis
[Musique]